vuelo táctico a los confines del sahel
en el extremo norte de mali esta es una
de las últimas rotaciones a la base
francesa entre shalit el puesto más
avanzado de la operación anti yihadista
haqqani
cuando el betis
actualmente estamos volando a 30 metros
sobre el suelo por si el enemigo nos ve
no tenga tiempo de atacarnos así que
estamos a muy baja altura y a muy alta
velocidad
es un día bastante especial para todos
los hombres y mujeres presentes en el
frente es ángel giano por primera vez
desde el inicio del enfrentamiento
francés en 2013 tres de sus bases son
evacuadas y transferidas a las fuerzas
malienses
una página pasa
repito han sido ocho años de presencia
en este sitio mucha gente se ha empleado
aquí necesariamente dejas una parte de
ti mismo una parte de tu corazón ninguno
puede permanecer insensible en momentos
como este entonces sí habrá una pequeña
punzada en el corazón
sí
d se vale
aquí estamos te pasamos la antorcha te
toca a ti continuar y como decimos en
casa buen viento y buena mar hotmail
es decir
me son bush y estoy feliz mis hombres
también de los refuerzos que han venido
durante varias semanas se han
beneficiado de un entrenamiento de
calidad para mantenerlos en esta
posición y defender este campamento a
toda costa
en tiffany alma seca
a la base de tessalit perdida en los
límites del norte de mali la frontera
con argelia es el puesto más avanzado y
expuesto de bajante en 24 horas ya no
habrá un soldado francés presente en
esta región disputada por varios grupos
yihadistas
el enemigo está presente pero invisible
lo sentimos sabemos que él está ahí que
nos está mirando y en este punto es
realmente diferente lo que podemos ver
cuando nos enfrentamos a la fuerza de
barkhan y más en el centro esto es por
supuesto también lo que explica la
reorganización del sistema las
organizaciones
es el fin de la operación francesa en el
norte de mali khan y sus aliados ángel
ya los europeos ahora se centrarán en el
área de las tres fronteras donde los
ataques terroristas han dejado cientos
de muertos en sólo unos pocos meses